[Music]
mr mayor good to see you oh it is the
mayor okay you're right you're mayor
yeah he looks younger you can tell by
his hair but let's watch it anyway
let me start by asking you where have
you been 522.2
million dollar shortfall last year we
had a 570 wait a minute 5.6 hank i'm
here to talk about tomorrow and today
and tomorrow now yesterday i've been
working my tail off i've been out i
think i had 69 public events the last
two and a half
nice
weeks you know i heard you say that on
the radio today and then i asked your
staff well where's the printout where
are these events
so what's happening here is i believe
this is the time when he was going to
these events and he was no showing them
and and you're a press person said well
this is stuff he just goes to these are
all public events yeah so but but look
you know the criticism that you have
been dodging not just the press but also
the public that you have been sulking
after dropping out of the governor's
race that is when you lost the
governor's race the first time you're
having a temper tantrum what do you want
to say about it
i want to say that
i've been working my tail off i've been
here
focused this is a guy
this is used car salesman energy with
this guy he's always been
yeah that of course
ah no that's not true at all
in san francisco i think i was gone two
days man
is he going to look for the bad boy of
karate right now
out of the city in the last three weeks
we've done 69 public events nice
nice
that's nice
and is engaged or more engaged than ever
uh i don't read the press uh it is you
should i mean you're the mayor of the
city i would listen super important can
i just say something if i were the mayor
i know i know i'll never be mayor of a
major city but if i were
i'd probably scoop up a copy of the
local paper every day right see what's
going on keep my finger on the pulse
right especially the paper of your city
right like if i were mayor of orlando
i'd scoop up a copy of the sentinel
every day see what's going on out there
uncle some of the things that have been
written so the cartoon in the chronicle
that depicted you as a crying baby
by the way these are all the same
reporters that are now lining up going
vote no on the reason oh yeah with the
headline did you see
though those the the woman that had the
mailbox keys that was taking all the bat
that that stole all the ballots in san
francisco the ballots are ready right
now for the to vote to vote for the
recall election and they have video
footage it was on the news of somebody
who had a mailbox here which we probably
worked for the post office these two
black women that were going to like
apartment big apartment complexes
opening up the mail thing and just
taking out stacks
of the uh recall ballots
by the way your mail vote for larry
elder everybody i know everybody has
their own little cute um
idea of who should win and they're like
that that by the way is going to keep
him in office is the fact that once
again
and nobody can get along on anything so
everybody's like no this guy's better
than larry elder no those cars but
everyone vote for larry elder he is by
the way probably not going to win anyway
but he's the only one in that group that
has a legitimate shot at beating him
vote for larry elder larry elder isn't
even the best choice
but he's the one with the with the most
momentum right now to beat this
vote for larry elder off the wall you
didn't see that no you didn't see why
who reads that stuff
newspapers i'll read that stuff i focus
on work i focus on getting things done
part of your work is
focusing on what the town is doing like
again
would i be paying attention to national
news a lot if i was the mayor of a town
probably not as much
but i would probably want to have a copy
every day of the paper of my town
all right and he's lying because you
know he reads it every day
of course he does but he's busy doing
work what is what does that mean
did you see the uh did you see the l.a
time the la times for you larry you
reminded me and it has to do with this
did you see the l.a times thing
no about larry elder just read the title
he's the black face of white supremacy
larry elder is the black face of white
supremacy according to the la times
what's the matter you didn't want to use
the phrase uncle tom was that was that a
little too did you think that was going
to be a little bit
right that's what that is exactly what
it is it's just a it's a roundabout way
of saying it
larry elder is the black face
of one they might as well have called
him a house and
i would have respected them more
erica d smith wrote this let's see erica
d smith erica d smith
erica she's fat i'm already guessing
she's fat
she's fat she's black
young and black
uh this is erica d smith she's empowered
as you'll be able to see here in a
second
i'm not going to be getting the latest
from her that's her
now you sent me this one um this is when
gavin newsom was on the adam corolla
show a few years ago 2013.
uh
i remember this because i remember
actually seeing this interview the whole
interview but let's see a little recap
here on mr recall this is amazing this i
i always liked corolla but this clip
made me love him oh yeah here we go
i want everybody to plan
look down the road six months yes your
husband lost his job that's why you need
to sock away some money when he's
gainfully employed
yes they foreclosed on your home that's
why you need to have a network a
community friends family members money
put on but think about it
half of african americans in the state
of california roughly half of latino
families have no access to a checking
account or an atm things we take for
granted they don't have a check what's
wrong with them and what but
i remember this i remember this segment
it's really good it's really good that's
well because they don't they don't have
the resources to sock those things away
why do we have them a
lot of different reasons but but roughly
half those families don't whether why do
armenians have them but
where they end up is check cashing
places
genetics are at play oh good
he's by the way he
obviously not that adam crowler believes
these things no no but i know what he's
doing but he's boxing him into this so
what's wrong with them is it are they
genetically inferior why are you giving
them why do they need a leg uh it's
amazing but okay so but do asians have
this problem i mean a lot of communities
have a lot of whites have these problems
that's not just black and hispanic no
but it
he already had him he already had to
have to go back and backtrack but why
did you bring up blackness because the
magnitude is ominous but why so many of
them it just happens to be it's just
that's the way god planned it
oh [ __ ] i forgot about this this is
amazing the way god planned it by the
way shout out to homo trollus because i
saw this clip on his instagram and i was
like oh [ __ ] i got to bring this to the
show not at all what happened to that
there are a lot of issues and with that
the communities are struggling
with immigrants
a lot of different reasons lack of
have been here longer and we've been
here well we can we can surmise what
about asians they were put in internment
camps yeah we in fact it all initiated
san francisco chinese exclusion act came
out so they progressed
because then the only reason why is the
magnitude
there's the probability more the
magnitude and percentage but there's no
way to figure out how that happens
oh this is great uh he's amazing
corolla [ __ ] rules and they always
unlike other people like corolla if you
actually like
read into how he got into it like the
guy we used to work on a construction
site every day like have you read about
how he started like he used to work on a
construction everyday i mean like i
think eight dollars an hour and he would
just work in the [ __ ] sun and he grew
up in a house with poor people yeah like
he grew up poor and [ __ ] so yeah he's
not this isn't like adam carl is not
some rich guy that was born in hollywood
and started doing radio like he was a
working class guy
we could talk about you know what i'm
dealing with i don't want to have a
sociological director sure
no here's why why would you would you
want to do that because the person from
the times wouldn't write good things
about it you could get that no no that's
not the case because i want a little bit
out of that no no you want to deal with
reality i want to deal with reality
people that are struggling people are
suffering i want to deal with the
problems why are they struggling
we can hold hands and surmise about all
these other reasons i don't want to do
that i don't know why they're struggling
why are they struggling a lot of folks
are struggling because they can't fight
why blacks because they're working white
blacks and hispanics across the board
also okay so everybody everybody's
struggling so asians are suffering just
as much as possible the face of welfare
is not an african-american family
it's asian jewish it's all of them
a lot of folks are struggling
for more of that
[Applause]
girl the rules man he [ __ ]
and there's just no way and there's no
way to figure out why that is why
the fact that he goes and there's ju so
you're saying there's just no way to
figure out why huh
he's [ __ ] brilliant jb's got a good
point adam carolla was the actual talent
behind the man show and he was jimmy
jimmy was funny don't get me wrong but
he wrote most of the stuff
um i mean
you know what you know what really
bothers me i bet they [ __ ] despise
each other now i've never really looked
into that they're friends are they still
friends
wow they just won't talk about politics
from what i understand but apparently
they're they're still they're still
friends oh
yeah
but you know i mean because in reality
let's be honest man kimmel doesn't
believe half the [ __ ] he says either
jimmy kimmel is just [ __ ] playing his
part and then um
and and and here you go here's what
happens isn't it does any is there
anybody left on the planet that it would
bother them to do that
and here's the videos that people are
making in san francisco
they're not they're not being paid or
anything about the voting no on the
recall i got my ballot and i'm ready to
vote oh no no no no no he got shots and
arms and a surplus too let's keep
california blue lady you're old stop
ballot
you're too old to be doing this ma'am
she has no furniture you have no
furniture and
ma'am you've got to be at least 35 years
old
she's just too old to be doing this
nothing sexy about this at all
it's a vote you have to vote nope no no
no no
like a 25 year old doing this it's kind
of hot
35 year old doing this uh it's a little
sexier if you don't make an answer
yourself
so you're going to vote no no no no no
well i'm not from california uh vote yes
if you're in california and listening to
this yes yes larry elder yes yes yes
larry elder that's all you and larry
elder because i not for any other reason
that i want to see newsome suffer
i want to see that man
suffer that is somebody who has a
you could catch it in that san francisco
mayor thing that we just played he has
it
but he's someone that rages and probably
screams at people around him he's a
complete sociopath you can just tell by
the way he's
like needs to be in control and like
like the way he suppresses that urge to
like deep down he's got that
patrick bateman like i want to take an
axe to this [ __ ] journalist right in
my office
speaking of which i made him uh i made a
comparison in the show links all right
let's check out the show links
see what we got here
oh wow frozen did this before you said
anything
it's
they're the same guy they are they
really are they're the same guy